monsieur le ministre mesdames Messieurs
chers collègues dans le cadre de son
étude sur la continuité territoriale
dans les rapporteurs sont Catherine
Cancun que je salue à un Martinique et
Guillaume Chevrollier nous faisons
escale aujourd'hui en Polynésie
française après l'océan Indien la
semaine dernière ces tables rondes
géographiques sont indispensables à nos
yeux pour saisir évidemment la diversité
et la complexité des situations et pour
élaborer les positions concrètes
d'amélioration étant actuellement à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon je vais suivre
la présente table ronde en
visioconférence mais le tien évidemment
à remercier les participants les
participants pour cette audition
importante notre vice-présidente
Micheline Jacques que je remercie très
chaleureusement animera à Paris cette
réunion en vous donnant bientôt la
parole et je tenais à saluer dès à
présent le représentant du gouvernement
de Polynésie française monsieur
Jean-Christophe ruisseau ministre du
Logement de l'aménagement en charge du
transport inter-insulaire monsieur Marc
Wallace directeur du service d'état de
l'aviation civile en Polynésie
et Monsieur Michel mon voisin président
directeur général
je vous remercions évidemment vivement
pour cette disponibilité vos éclairages
bonne audition à tous et Micheline je te
souhaite de maintenant la parole
merci Président mes chers collègues
mesdames messieurs bon ce jour Monsieur
le Ministre
puisqu'il est 8h à Papeete qu'il est 19h
à Paris vous allez donc avoir la parole
à tour de rôle dans l'ordre que le
président n'a pas tout à fait énoncé que
je vais énoncer dans une pour une
dizaine de minutes chacun a fait de
présenter vos observations donc vous
vous appuierez sur la trame qui vous a
été transmise vous pourrez aussi
transmettre ultérieurement d'autres
précisions par écrit ensuite les
rapporteurs interviendront pour vous
demander certaines questions puis ce
sera le tour des autres collègues je
vais laisser la parole à Monsieur
Jean-Christophe Bouissou ministre du
Logement de l'aménagement charge du
transport inter insulaire monsieur le
ministre c'est à vous
[Musique]
à l'ensemble des membres de votre
commission et les sénateurs
que nous prenons ce temps de parole avec
vous pour évoquer évidemment cette
question importante sur la continuité
territoriale entre un autre pays la
police française
située à 17000 km évidemment de
l'hexagone et puis
et puis la France Paris en fonction des
compagnies aériennes qui utilisent
évidemment ces trajets
il y a un certain nombre de questions
qui ont été posées bien évidemment nos
amis de Polynésie
présidente
Michel mon voisin
le directeur général de
rettings
[Musique]
ainsi que nos amis de la de la descente
locale pour cette occasion alors vous
allez poser un certain nombre de
questions en fait qui constitue autour
de la trame de des réponses que nous
souhaitons apporter à vos
questionnements est-ce que vous
souhaitez que l'on passe question en
question par question ou souhaitez-vous
que j'aborde moi directement et je
déroule finalement les précisions que
nous pourrions apporter à vos
questionnements
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez le
faire globalement et s'il y a des points
sur lesquels vous voulez insistez vous
avez vous insisterez on vous laisse
faire
[Musique]
française nous avons
de compagnie aériennes qui décède donc
le pays et en particulier s'agissant des
compagnies aériennes qui
rentrent dans le cadre des questions de
continuité territoriale nous en avons
précisément trois
au travers de RTL
France et puis de Frenchville sur la
question qu'il faut savoir si l'offre de
transport
aérien avec l'hexagone et
[Musique]
constitue une des fréquences
intéressantes pour la Polynésie je
dirais que évidemment c'est toujours en
fonction des marchés
compagnie aérienne
mettre en place des fréquences de
desserts
en fonction du marché évidemment du
marché polynésiennes aussi du marché
touristique
depuis l'hexagone depuis d'autres pays
puisque les avions qui viennent de Paris
passent par les États-Unis et font un
transit sur l'ensemble de l'Est ou sur
San Francisco sur également
l'état de Washington
donc
c'est donc le parcours effectué par les
avions et nous avons comparativement à
la situation antérieure à la covid 19
une légère augmentation des fréquences
avec un vol supplémentaire créer des
serres donc la Polynésie sur cet aspect
en nombre de sièges et sur les questions
de saisonnalité on peut dire que la
Polynésie est très bien desservie par
ces trois compagnies aériennes que je
viens de citer sachant bien entendu que
la concurrence est très très forte
puisque on voit que
depuis l'ouverture du ciel a polynésien
et en particulier sur les destinations
plus régionales de des États-Unis avec
l'avenue de Delta Airlines récemment ou
la venue de
de United ou d'autres compagnies
aériennes comme un moyen Airlines on
voit bien que en Polynésie une certaine
forme d'émulation
qui se produit avec un grand intérêt de
nouvelles compagnies à des servir la
Polynésie alors sur la question a été
posée savoir si des analyses ont été
réalisées des tests de marché en
fonction des compagnies qui
servent donc la Polynésie les tests en
question c'est à dire le délicieux de
marché généralement réalisé par les
compagnies aériennes
[Musique]
local et notamment avec les compagnies
existantes pour savoir comment est-ce
que ces compagnies allaient absorber
cette concurrence sachant que notre
volonté et de permettre aussi notamment
herpétine et c'est aussi le cas de la
France pour de frenchy de ne pas bâtir
de cette concurrence nouvelle qui
viendrait au travers de ces nouvelles
compagnies
enfin de tel état ont également leur
réseau qui le transport à partir
d'autres États des États-Unis
vers l'Europe et donc indirectement cela
tout cela constitue aussi
ils ont une concurrence
indirecte à nos compagnies
sur les lignes
vers la colonie au départ de la
Polynésie je vous dis tout de suite il
n'y a pas de DSP sur le plan de
la desserte entre sur l'international et
entre la Polynésie et puis et puis
l'Hexagone il y a bien une tentative qui
était réalisée en 2001
par le gouvernement d'époque avec une
contestation devant le Conseil d'État au
Conseil d'État annulé cette décision qui
a été prise de créer une délégation de
service public
entre la Polynésie et la France
métropolitaine
par contre nous avons une délégation de
on en parlera tout à l'heure puisque
cela c'est l'objet d'une question chez
vous de votre part pardon sur la
continuité intérieure en Polynésie
puisque la Polynésie c'est un pays comme
vous le savez que l'Europe avec une
étendue maritime qui nécessite le fait
de se déplacer en avion et nous avons 78
îles qui sont habitées en Polynésie et
on connaît donc l'importance au lait
l'aérien sur la décès d'intérieur et la
nécessité de maintenir certaines routes
déficitaires
le directeur général de la tétine pour
un certain nombre d'en parler à tout à
l'heure et cette délégation service
public a été mise en place par le
gouvernement permet de maintenir ses
lignes sur les
34 aéroports que nous avons qui rentrent
à l'intérieur de cette délégation de
service public
on regarde les autres aéroports qui
demeurent dans le domaine de
concurrentiel donc
il n'y a pas
on va se dire de délégation service
public entre la Polynésie et la France
vous souhaitez également que l'on vous
donne quelques
informations et quelques précisions sur
les dispositifs en vigueur concernant la
continuité territoriale
par voie aérienne et poser une question
savoir quelle est la part du prix total
d'un billet d'avion
qu'est-ce que représente ce qui en
moyenne alors sachez que
nous avons donc une aide à la continuité
territoriale qui est évidemment apprécié
des passagers
c'est une aide qui est
consenti évidemment pour les familles à
revenus modeste
[Musique]
c'est une aide de consenti à des gens
qui ont des revenus
et c'est une c'est une aide qui est qui
était allouée en 2022 et totalement
consommé sur le pont du budget c'est
donc 40 % du prix d'un billet d'avion
puisque cette continuité territoriale
représente une aide de 76000 francs
pacifiques qui représente
640 642 euros et qui représente donc
environ 40% de publier sachant que
préjugés varie et
c'est d'ailleurs l'objet d'une de vos
questions s'aperçoit bien qu'il y a une
variation à la hausse à des prix des
billets d'avion
depuis la réouverture du ciel
avec en particulier
l'augmentation des prix du baril de
pétrole et évidemment ces conséquences
sur les dérivés en termes de
Georg fioul utilisé par par les avions
c'est ce qui est occasionné évidemment
la hausse sur le plan d'ailleurs vous
posez une question sur le fait de savoir
si la baisse tarifaire enfin la baisse
du prix du pari constaté a eu quelques
conséquences sur les billets d'avion
c'est pas l'impression qu'on a et il
faut dire aussi que entre une baisse
boursière et la répercussion réelle sur
les tarifs de l'aérien et de face à un
certain temps
pour pour le constater
et je dirais aussi que
la plupart des compagnies aériennes je
crois que c'est le cas de vérité sinon
il n'a pas répercuté la hausse du prix
du baril depuis son nom voler
mon voisin pour en parler tout à l'heure
et peut-être aussi explique le fait que
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas je dirais
une répercussion tout de suite à la
baisse sur les prix des billets
alors sur la continuité territoriale
toujours
le ministère de l'Éducation locale
au titre du transport des étudiants non
boursiers nous avons donc une aide à la
continuité territoriale qui représente
ce que je viens de dire 40 % du tarif
aller-retour et que c'est applicable à
la gamme évidemment étudiante
proposé par les compagnies aériennes
puisque les compagnies aériennes
concentrent
des tarifs préférentiels pour cette
catégorie de de passagers
et l'aide à la continuité territoriale
on le sait c'est la volonté de
gouvernement centrale devrait être vu à
la hausse en raison certainement des
augmentations de Paris au cours de
l'année 2023 Julie quelque part que
c'était une hausse substantielle que
évidemment les les populations acides
vont apprécier puisque je crois qu'on
fasse de 76000 francs pacifiques à 111
et quelque chose
c'est quand même une hausse très
importante qui nécessitera à la force
des choses une augmentation également du
budget
pour nous interroger également sur
l'action de l'État qui gère ses aides
dans notre territoire
et vous vous faites référence évidemment
à la réforme des aides intervenues en
2021 qui nous interrogeait sur sur sa
pertinence et puis vous vous demandez si
l'album intervient sur notre territoire
la donne intervient mais au travers d'un
dispositif qui est propre
la mise en place par l'État du pôle de
continuité territoriale
qui assure donc ici le traitement est
suivi des dossiers des passeports
mobilités et compris formation
professionnelle donc il y a bien un
dispositif local avec une prise en
charge afin de l'État je sais pour être
un peu plus spécifique que cette cellule
comprend 5 personnes et avec une
déconcentration de prise en charge des
demandes notamment au niveau des îles
souvent et des Marquises
et ce
dispositif
fonctionne bien
c'est un dispositif qui
que l'on retrouve au côté d'un
dispositif propre à la Polynésie
française qui concerne évidemment les
boursiers
prise en charge par le pays sur le biais
depuis leurs
îles jusque en métropole donc c'est sur
la base de cette politique que nous
avons
envers les boursiers polynésiens qui
bénéficie également de la prise en
charge à 100%
du billet d'avion et du remboursement du
ticket
entre les îles et l'île de Tahiti ou le
seul aéroport international est situé
sur l'île sur l'île principale c'est
peut-être là où on pourrait apporter une
amélioration sur le dispositif de l'État
et
ouvrir cette prise en charge sur le plan
de
mobilité ou la continuité territoriale
depuis le lieu de résidence
des Polynésiens sachant que quelqu'un
qui vit au marquise et qui doit se
rendre en métropole qui souhaitent se
rendre en métropole doit aussi
payer son billet d'avion
parler plus spécifiquement de ce que ça
représente en termes de taille faible je
ne trompe pas trop si l'on dit que le
tarif allait retour depuis les Marquises
nous pouvons
600 euros et 600 euros c'est pas rien
sur je dirais un budget global pour des
gens qui n'ont pas forcément le pouvoir
d'achat que l'on peut connaître par
ailleurs donc c'est c'est un dispositif
ici qui fonctionne bien encore une fois
c'est je voudrais saluer également le
travail réalisé par les services au
commissariat localement avec une durée
de traitement des dossiers de l'ordre
d'une dizaine de jours c'est c'est très
fini et je présume que les questions de
dématérialisation ou de raison
d'Internet
permettrait aussi
de réguler les temps d'attente et de
communication surtout avec les
populations dans les îles dans un
contexte que nous avons aujourd'hui en
Polynésie d'Internet aujourd'hui dans
les îles principales donc c'est un bon
moyen pour rapprocher évidemment les
populations des administrations y
compris des administrations d'État
je poursuis si vous voulez bien
[Musique]
succession de questionnement concernant
les
collectivités
[Musique]
a mis en place des aides à quantité
territoriale en complément
indépendamment des aides de l'État j'ai
demandé de préciser évidemment
les modalités et montant de chez elle
jouait pour vous il n'y a pas donc de
dispositif de continuité territoriale
mise en place par notre collectivité en
Polynésie française on s'entend bien sur
la continuité territoriale et on peut ré
dans un caractéristiques de droit commun
et qui permettrait tout un chacun et
même des conditions de ressources
pourquoi bénéficier de tarifs
préférentiels prise en charge par la
collectivité donc il n'y a pas on
Polynésie mise à part cette politique
prise en charge par l'État sur la
continuité territoriale sur le passeport
mobilité il n'y a pas dans notre pays un
dispositif d'ailleurs j'ai évoquais tout
à l'heure et je crois même savoir que le
Conseil d'État a réagi sur une
un souhait ou une volonté de l'île de la
Réunion de mettre en place un dispositif
de service public de ce type et donc on
a bien compris que ce n'est pas aux
collectivités de prendre en charge c'est
question de continuité territoriale je
vous disais tout à l'heure nous on l'a
fait par contre localement je peux
peut-être profiter pour
vous demandera à une question qui peut
dans votre questionnaire nous avons mis
en place maintenant depuis deux ans
une déviation de service public
cela écrit en lui nécessaire par toute
cette période de la covid et qui a fait
que notre compagnie aérienne locale
affective ne pouvait plus assumer selon
une péripatation interne à la compagnie
entre des routes profitables comme les
îles soulevant
au travers des billets d'avion payés par
les passagers touristes ou par la
population locale le récompensé les
pertes occasionnés sur ces lignes des
autres
îles de la Polynésie et au nom de 34 sur
47 aéroports pour essayer de vous prenez
une la configuration et dépend du réseau
de transport et les infrastructures que
nous avons en Polynésie française
donc les
RCCI a été contraints d'arrêter les vols
et les directeurs pour nous cette
situation n'était pas décisive et nous
avons travaillé à la mise en place d'un
fonds de continuité territoriale qui est
alimenté par une contribution sur les
billets d'avion sur le plan local payer
par tout le monde que ce soit les
étrangers les touristes soit
évidemment des Polynésiens eux même
selon deux tarifs différenciés entre les
zones de livres concurrence où les zones
évidemment les plus éloignés ce sont
permet aujourd'hui
de d'équilibrer le
équilibrer ces lignes déficitaires
tout à l'heure au nombre de 34 et ce
sont généralement les idées pour un
contenu des Marquises mais aussi un peu
des Australes qui bénéficient dans cette
crise en charge au niveau du pays
ce qui est intéressant avec ce
dispositif c'est que les tarifs sont
fixés par un arrêté du Gouvernement
c'est-à-dire que le Gouvernement fixe
les fréquences et fixe également le
niveau parfait possible évidemment pour
l'opérateur de faire des tarifs moins
élevés
ceci dit la régulation dans ce domaine
et réaliser par le Conseil des ministres
et cela peut arriver que l'on puisse
réviser annuellement en fonction de la
situation
la situation du fond nous permet par
exemple
entrevoir en 2023 des discussions avec
la compagnie aquatique qui assure sa
délégation de service public pour faire
baisser des paris sur des lignes de
films qui sont éloignés et de même que
les augmentations de fréquence
au niveau de ces îles et
particulièrement dans les îles qui ont
le souhait de se de développer du
tourisme et d'augmenter donc les
fréquences sur l'aérien pour que cela
devienne plausible
donc c'est un dispositif qui coûte à la
Polynésie française au travers des fonds
passager elle
environ un milliard de 100 millions de
francs c'est à dire 10
10 millions d'euros
et c'est un fond qui fonctionne
qui fonctionnait au début avec des
subventions de la Polynésie française en
partie qui fonctionne aujourd'hui bien
grâce évidemment aux recettes
recueillies sur les passages
au nom de la Communauté française un
courrier a été transmis par le président
Édouard Philippe au mois de janvier
une contribution de l'État à
l'alimentation de ce fond
j'ai eu l'occasion il y a quelques mois
de rencontrer le ministre des Transports
monsieur giébaris à cette époque-là pour
voir dans quelle mesure les vins
pouvaient nous accompagner pour agir
encore plus sur la baisse tarifaire non
pas pour compenser éventuellement des
subventions versées par le gouvernement
local mais
pour baisser véritablement les tarifs
sur ces destinations qui sont des
destinations
très éloignées de 1000 ou 1200 ou 1500
km depuis papeter évidemment plus on est
dans une région éloignée que les
familles sont élevés donc c'est une
voilà je souhaitais souligner cet aspect
dans le cadre de notre mission au niveau
de la commission monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs pour
voilà simplement attirer
la tension des phases sur la manière
dont la continuité territoriale pourrait
se poursuivre y compris sur le fait de
participer au financement sur plan local
de cette délégation de service public
qui a été mise en place je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre pour vos propos
très complets et très éclairants je vais
laisser la parole à Monsieur
voilà
directeur de l'aviation civile en
Polynésie française
écoutez mesdames et messieurs et
sénateurs monsieur le ministre du
Logement d'aménagement en charge du
transport messieurs les directeurs et
compagnies aériennes mesdames et
messieurs je tiens d'abord à vous
remercier et notamment remercier la
délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer
pour leur invitation à partir de
participer à cette table ronde consacrée
à la continuité territoriale entre
l'hexagone et la politique française
donc mon nom est Marc voilà je suis
effectivement le directeur des services
de l'État d'addition civile en Polynésie
française le CAPF et je suis en
compagnie aujourd'hui du directeur
adjoint Charles Perretti alors peut-être
quelques mots rapides sur le rôle du
seat PF notre rôle est triple nous
exerçons les prérogatives de l'autorité
de surveillance en matière de sécurité
aérienne et de sûreté pour l'ensemble de
la poignée française notre rôle est
ainsi de veiller à ce que les opérateurs
de l'écosystème aéronautique respectent
et appliquent la réglementation en
matière de sécurité de sûreté et bien
sûr et bien sûr de les accompagner
dans les éventuels actions correctives
qui doivent mettre en oeuvre d'autre
part je représente également le haut
commissaire ainsi que le directeur
général d'aviation civile pour les
missions régaliennes en matière
d'aviation civile notamment en matière
de sûreté d'environnement et de
régulation économique et bien sûr dans
la vis-à-vis de l'accompagnement de la
filière aéronautique enfin une
particularité qui est propre à la
politique française par rapport à aux
autres territoires
le CAPF est en charge des services du
contrôle aérien donc peut-être en
propolémina je vous propose vous
présenter quelques éléments de contexte
du transport aérien entre la zone
polonaisie française et l'hexagone et
puis ensuite une description rapide et
d'infrastructures existantes je vous
décrirai la perception nous avons de
l'offre actuelle de transport ainsi que
des tarifs appliqués alors tout d'abord
sur les infrastructures aéroportuaires
et leur trafic donc la politique
française comme le disait le
ministre monsieur le ministre c'est un
aéroport international international et
un maillage extraordinaire de 46
aéroports commerciaux domestiques 46 et
ceci dans un espace de la taille de
l'Europe
c'est infrastructure aéroportuaire sont
stratégique vraiment stratégique pour la
connectivité de notre territoire et
garantissent la continuité territoriale
entre l'hexagone et nos îles en termes
de trafic l'année 2022 a vu une forte
reprise du trafic bien au-delà des
attentes principalement portées par des
augmentations de liaison augmentation
des fréquences de d'Air France de 3 à 5
par semaine de United de 3 à 5 même si
c'est pas sur l'axe métropolitain
l'arrivée Delta avec trois fréquences
entre Papeete et Los Angeles mais aussi
d'une certaine façon l'ouverture récente
de la de la desserte de Seattle par nos
amis de Desert oui donc ça c'est
globalement nous ce que l'on ressent
vis-à-vis de du trafic et la façon dont
le trafic a rebondi en colonie française
alors je vous propose maintenant de
faire une description rapide du paysage
concurrentiel puis de vous donner
quelques chiffres sur l'évolution de
l'offre de siège et des fréquences en
distinguant bien sûr le trafic entre
papeter et l'Hexagone ainsi que le
trafic entre papeté et les territoires
de la Polynésie française alors sur la
partie Papeete hexagone ce sont
aujourd'hui trois compagnies aériennes
Air tahitiwi Air France friendsby qui
propose des vols entre Tahiti et
l'hexagone et dans notre cas c'est Paris
exclusivement
avec une vraie concurrence saine entre
le transporteur un autre sens l'offre
actuelle est suffisante aujourd'hui nous
disposons de 11 fréquences hebdomadaires
entre papeter et Paris soit 4400 sièges
par semaine
offerts et répartis de la façon suivante
Air France 5 fréquences
RTI 4 fréquences French be de fréquence
ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui c'est que
l'offre actuelle est supérieure à la
période précovide qui était de 9
fréquences en 2019 donc nous avons
plutôt un rebond très favorable de la de
la de la du trafic aérien et quelque
part finalement de l'offre l'offre
proposée
aux habitants de la politique française
à cette offre entre papeter et Paris on
peut rajouter le renforcement de la
ligne entre papeter Los Angeles avec
l'arrivée de United Airlines et de Delta
qui permet de laisser un certain nombre
de passagers des vols entre papeter et
Paris puisque en fait tous ces vols vers
la métropole vers l'Hexagone s'arrête en
los Angeles ou à San Francisco donc
toute ligne entre Los Angeles San
Francisco et papetti et susceptible de
délester donc un seul nombre de
passagers de des vols vers la métropole
le trafic entre Papeete et les
territoires de la Polynésie française
actuellement sur les 46 aérodromes
domestiques commerciaux 12 sont dans le
secteur et c'est ce que disait monsieur
le ministre d'où sont dans le secteur de
la libre concurrence et 34 routes sont
des servi à travers une DSP du pays la
compagnie Air Tahiti et Émilie et
attributaire de la DSP financée par le
pays à hauteur d'environ 10 millions
d'euros
sur la zone de libre concurrence Air
Tahiti sera désormais en compétition
avec Moana ceci des mi-février 2023 et
en cours d'année 2023 c'est possible
nous ne savons pas vraiment totalement
par motholunk moto Link qui est une
société qui nous a demandé un dans une
compagnie aérienne qui nous a demandé un
CTA donc un certificat transporteur
aérien en nous disant qu'elle opérer
dans le courant de l'année 2023 donc
nous aurons sur les le segment le plus
porteur et de fait le plus concurrentiel
trois compagnies aériennes au lieu d'en
avoir une seule
surtout sur ce segment papeté territoire
apolis françaises le trafic domestique a
rapidement retrouvé un niveau proche de
2019 dès le début 2022 donc en fait un
rebond très très fort dès 2022 notamment
grâce à des incitations financières
favorables du pays à destination des
populations locales
en 2019 le trafic passager de Messi
était de 750 à environ 750 000 passagers
en 2020 il était de 750 000 parlant 2019
était 750 000 en 2020 de 420 000 donc
vous voyez il n'y a pas eu
d'effondrement réellement par rapport au
à la diagonale ou à la métropole et en
2021 il était de 518 donc déjà un petit
rebond et des et ce chiffre de 518 sur
l'année 2022 était déjà dépassé
en septembre 2022
graphique de
2021 qui était au global de 518 était
déjà dépassé en 2022 dès le 37 ans et
donc très clairement on sera en 2022 à
un trafic fin 2022 on sera un trafic
entre papeter et les territoires de
police française qui seront très
supérieurs qui sera supérieur déjà à
celui de 2019
sur les tarifs alors comme vous le savez
la parité la liberté tarifaire et la
règle pour les transporteurs entre
l'hexagone et les et les territoires
d'outre-mer endroit européen des
aménagements tarifaire sont toutefois
possibles sur certaines conditions et
notamment liées à l'imposition
d'obligation de service public prévu par
le droit européen de telles obligations
déjà été fixées pour les liaison entre
l'hexagone et les régions
ultra-périgphériques qui prévoit en
particulier des réductions tarifaires
obligatoires pour les mineurs les
étudiants les personnes en deuillées
ainsi bien sûr que des possibilités
d'évacuation sanitaire la concurrence
effective sur liaison vers Tahiti ainsi
qu'à difficulté à démontrer notamment
des besoins vitaux pour le développement
économique et social de ces territoires
font que le cadre juridique européen ne
permet pas de démontrer j'allais dire la
proportionnalité d'une mesure imposant
des prix maximum si jamais il était
envisagé une extension des contrats de
tar actuelle sur ses liaisons
en l'occurrence ses besoins vitaux qui
sont bien réels tels que la formation la
santé et pour lesquelles les prix
résultant de l'initiative commerciale
transporteurs peuvent paraître
quelquefois quelques fois faire sont
bien pris en compte par les aides
sociales instaurer dans le cadre de la
continuité territoriale
pour un billet aller-retour la part de
la continuité territoriale est en
moyenne d'environ 40% d'un billet
aller-retour pour un billet aller simple
les chiffres du Haut Commissariat
font état d'une part de l'aide qui
peuvent qui peut aller entre 80 et 90%
bien sûr c'est par peut évoluer selon le
choix de la compagnie aérienne de la
sosanie saisonnalité au moment de la
date du départ
l'enveloppe annuelle allouée pour
financer ses dispositifs de fonds de
continuité territoriale en Polynésie
Polynésie parlant s'élève à million
d'euros sur l'exercice budgétaire 2022
le pôle de la continuité territoriale du
Haut-Commissariat a consommé 100% des
crédits des crédits de fonds de
continuité de la continuité territoriale
en Polynésie française notamment pour
les jeunes en formation ou en études
toutefois afin de compenser la hausse
j'allais dire on le verra plus tard
inéluctable du prix du billet d'avion et
de contribuer le pouvoir d'achat des
résultats des résidents ultramarins le
ministère délégué aux outre-mer souhaite
apporter en 2023 une évolution à la
politique nationale de continuité
territoriale et il est d'ores et déjà
envisagé en 2023 une revalorisation du
montant forfaitaire de l'aide à la
continuité territoriale qui passera de
640 euros à 935 euros par voyageur et
bien sûr et c'était pas forcément
totalement évident les conditions
d'éligibilité requises actuelles
resteront
identiques donc en termes de résidence
et de plafond des revenus
sur le volet évolution des prix les
compagnies aériennes restent bien
entendu les mieux placés pour donner des
informations détaillées sur leur
politique tarifaire quelques éléments de
contexte néanmoins pour comprendre la
construction des prix elle passe d'abord
par une compréhension des coûts
les structures de coupe peuvent être
très variables en fonction de la taille
de la compagnie du type de route
exploitée du type de service proposé
néanmoins une constante reste la part
prépondérante du coût du carburant des
salaires des personnels et d'une
certaine façon des redevances
ainsi que des taxes et tous ces éléments
tous ces éléments ont augmenté ces
derniers temps et auquel cas et il
faudrait également rajouter à
l'augmentation de l'ensemble de ces
éléments de coûts la parité
euro ou dollars qui n'arrange rien vous
savez que dans le monde aéronautique la
plupart des transactions ne se font en
dollars on peut payer en dollars et
l'augmentation le renchérissement du
dollar par rapport à l'euro n'a rien
fait pour aider les compagnies aériennes
à maintenir à contenir leur pouvoir
un autre élément qui influence fortement
la conscience des prix et l'utilisation
par les compagnies aériennes de
techniques de gestion et de la recette
qu'on appelle le yil management qui
conduisent pour un même vol à proposer
une multitude de tarifs différents afin
de répondre aux attentes et contraintes
des voyageurs et bien sûr afin de
maximiser
en tout cas optimiser la recette des
compagnies aériennes ainsi les tarifs
varient en fonction de la classe de
voyage de la date de réservation de la
date de la durée du séjour des
conditions d'échange une modification de
billets donc il est très très difficile
de s'y retrouver ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que s'il y a eu une hausse et très
serment très sincèrement nous ne la
percevons pas s'il y avait eu une hausse
des billets d'avion sur un an celle-ci
peut s'expliquer par une série de
facteurs propres à l'ensemble des
transporteur aérien comme je vous le
disais au général des coûts il y a
l'inflation notamment notamment les
coûts salariaux hausse plus spécifiques
du coup les carburants une évolution
défavorable de la parité euro contre
dollar
les transporteurs Deven faire face à
l'augmentation de leur coût
d'exploitation et disposant d'une
trésorerie nous le dirons fragiliser par
la crise sanitaire il se retrouve
contraint de reporter au moins en partie
tout os sensible de leur coup sur le
prix des billets si sa vérité qui a eu
une hausse des prix en 2022 s'il s'avère
qu'il y a une housse des prix en 2022 ce
qui est loin d'être montré cette
dernière relève d'un effet de rattrapage
et la tendance on a pas contre regardé
la tendance structurelle sur les 10
dernières années elles ont plutôt une
une baisse ou un contingent
ces moyennes annuelles ne doivent
toutefois pas
occulter la forte saisonnalité des prix
notamment lors des puits de trafic
constaté lors de la période estivale ou
celle des fin d'année des fêtes de fin
d'année
pour résumer en conclusion
un paysage concurrentiel et présent pour
les liaisons entre l'hexagone et la
politique française cette concurrence a
contribué à augmenter l'offre de sièges
et les fréquences de vol ainsi qu'à
amortir finalement la hausse des coûts
d'exploitation par les compagnies
aériennes les tarifs actuels étant
sensiblement équivalent à ceux de 2019
les prix sont comme partout néanmoins
soumis à une forte saisonnalité les prix
étant plus élevés au moment des prix de
trafic voilà en ce qui concerne
l'analyse du cercle poly français
merci monsieur je vais laisser la parole
à Monsieur manaté viviche directeur
général d'Air Tahiti
bonjour tout le monde
mesdames sénateurs bonjour je vise
président et Romain
je
ne suis pas directement concerné en fait
par les interrogations que vous avez
étant étant en compagnie aérienne
domestique
ne desservons pas la métropole ceci dit
il y a un certain nombre de questions
qui effectivement
relève dans la télépathie pour un féti
et je m'associe tout à fait en fait
à l'intervention faite par le
vice-président sur la description des
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place par
le la politique française par le pays
notamment donc les délégations de
service public alors
[Musique]
effectivement réalisé et réalise
toujours jusqu'à l'arrivée de nouvelles
compagnies aériennes qui devrait
commencer l'ajouter la science cette
année
la desserte de l'ensemble des
destinations polynésiennes c'est-à-dire
46 destinations
et effectivement
c'est cette statutivité était rendue
possible grâce à un système de
pellequation interne que nous avons
historiquement mis en place et qui nous
permettait de compenser et perte
des tarifs qui étaient proposés sur les
lignes je dirais excédentaires sur les
lignes touristiques principalement celle
des îles souvent avec volabre en tête
par exemple donc ce système a été
mise à mal effectivement par la crise du
covid
les touristes n'arrivant plus pour les
îles françaises et qui n'a plus été en
mesure de compenser ces déficits et
c'est dangereux tourner vers le pays
pour que des solutions soient mises en
place et le pays a effectivement
réagit assez rapidement en mettant en
place des deux délégations de service
pour être précis c'est délégation de
service public le président en a parlé
le vice-président on a parlé sans
délégation de service public qui
[Musique]
permettent au pays de contribuer en fait
à la desserte de ces destinations
éloignées à faible population à hauteur
de 10 millions d'euros à peu près
sortie de ce dispositif qui est financé
d'ailleurs par une contribution prélevée
sur payé par financé par les passagers
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de d'aide
particulière
existantes aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
la relation
[Musique]
voilà c'est à peu près tout ce que je
peux malheureusement vous dire sur le
sujet n'étant pas me désavant pas la
métropole
concernant le prix du carburant il a
effectivement quasiment doublé pour nous
sur l'exercice 2022 il est passé et nous
avons subi une augmentation de l'ordre
de 104% sur le pays du carburant
il y a effectivement eu un effet dollar
sur sur assez fortement ressenti sur nos
charges c'est fait dollars se
manifestant au travers de l'augmentation
du prix du carburant puisque le Caluire
est payé en dollars donc non seulement
on a eu une augmentation du prix du
pétrole on va le rassurer mais nous
avons aussi un double effet du fait
d'augmentation du taux de
ce todo là qui a augmenté a d'ailleurs
aussi largement impacté l'effet
d'approche notamment l'effet de
maintenance des coups de maintenance de
la compagnie mais il faut aussi pas
perdre de vue que lorsque le dollar
était levé et du coup la destination
polynésienne devient moins onéleuse pour
les touristes américains qui constituent
un marché relativement important pour la
poésie française ce qui explique
notamment l'influence de touristes
américains en partie je pense sur la
destination pour les yeux française sur
à l'occasion de l'exercice 2022
concernant les taxes perçues sur les
prix du billet elles sont variable en
fonction de
[Musique]
des billets eux-mêmes quoi de la valeur
absolue du prix des billets mais je
dirais que grosso modo nous sommes sur
des une échelle de l'ordre de 10 à 25 %
du prix du billet au global sur les
taxes perçus par les passagers
voyageurs sur les lignes intérieures
nous avons pour global en termes de
politique talifère
décidé l'année dernière de ne pas
répercuter les hausses de collier à un
environnement inflationniste tel que
nous avons pu le connaître et qui a été
particulièrement sévère en poésie
française cela à l'aune d'une
augmentation des trafics
les volumes de trafic nous ayons permis
de compenser d'une certaine façon un
petit peu la
[Musique]
l'augmentation de nos charges donc les
trafics des tarifs entre en moyenne sur
2022 BC de 5%
voilà ce que je peux vous dire jusqu'à
présent complément de des interventions
précédentes qui ont été particulièrement
complètes sur les différents sujets que
qui vous intéressent merci Monsieur le
Directeur je vais laisser la parole
maintenant à Monsieur Michel mon voisin
président directeur général d'Air Tahiti
nuit
merci bonjour mesdames messieurs
sénateurs bonjour bonjour
à notre vice-président monsieur Bouissou
nos amis du SEAC
oui donc moi je
justement peut-être en introduction pour
présenter RTI puisque effectivement la
particularité de la Polynésie c'est
qu'il y a un venait d'entendre le
directeur général la compagnie
domestique et nous nous desservons
l'international
ATN est une société d'économie mixte une
scène qui est détenue à 85 % par la
collectivité nous desservons
principalement donc l'Hexagone via Los
Angeles
Los Angeles CDG Charles de Gaulle les
États-Unis donc via Los Angeles mais
également avec des vols directs sur Los
Angeles et depuis peu sur Seattle et
prochainement à l'été un Seattle CDG le
Pacifique vient alimenter via notre
notre route sur Auckland avec des
accords derrière pour
toucher l'Australie par exemple et nous
avons donc les papiers Auckland et
ensuite le E Basic et Narita au niveau
des servons papeter Marita avec une
route qui est pas encore réouverte c'est
les suites de la precovide donc nous
c'est une route ça doit être ça doit
être la dernière route que nous allons
réouvrir qui est prévu pour faire
octobre 2023
ça c'est globalement c'est une petite
synthèse sur ATN la question je j'ai
sous les yeux vos questions donc sur les
questions d'ordre général bon c'est vrai
que notre vice-président et Marc Walla
en bien déblayé le terrain donc je me
contenterai peut-être d'être un peu de
compléter leur de compléter leurs
interventions ça laissera peut-être un
peu plus de place aux questions
sur les questions d'ordre général
d'abord sur l'offre de transport aérien
ce qui est intéressant
un sujet qui a la Polynésie qui est
intéressé Yata pourquoi parce que ils
ont été surpris de la croissance c'est
d'après Yata c'est un record mondial une
croissance aussi forte sur les routes
principales en précovide avec l'arrivée
de United et French be il y avait déjà
eu 30 % de croissance
augmentation des capacités
après le covid en 2022
a vu une nouvelle croissance de 39% de
l'offre en siège
donc je vous laisse imaginer 39% de
croissance sur Charles de Gaulle en peu
de temps c'est ce que ce que ça générer
en termes de fréquentation
de
français de tarifs et tout ce qui suit
ensuite sur les infrastructures donc il
a fallu absorber cette
[Musique]
concurrence cette surcapacité
qui fait que nous avons grosso modo
alors sur la Polynésie nous avons
maintenant une offre en siège à peu près
et à peu près un million de sièges vers
la Polynésie un peu plus d'un million de
sièges en français
si on prend des allers-retours parce
qu'en général la Polynésie c'est un
aller-retour peu de compagnie vendent
des années simples ça sent
principalement de l'aller-retour à peu
près une offre capable de transporter un
peu plus de 600 000 passagers entre 600
650 000 passagers annuellement il y a
50000 polynésiens qui voyagent à peu
près parce qu'il y a une population de
300 000 habitants et la capacité
réceptive du
territoire et de l'ordre de entre 260
peut-être 280 000 touristes donc voilà
donc je je vous laisse imaginer la
surcapacité ce qui fait que la
surcapacité mécaniquement ça entraîne
une guerre des prix et une baisse des
forcément bah surtout en classe
économique donc nous sommes nous sommes
en pleine de danse on mange je dirais
que c'est un peu la jungle c'est c'est
la guerre c'est la guerre c'est la
guerre des prix on arrive aujourd'hui à
vendre des
on arrive avant avoir des tarifs publiés
par certaines concurrents alors
évidemment forcément au bout d'un moment
tout le monde s'allume on arrive à avoir
des tarifs entre
sur des Los Angeles Papeete qui est là
où il y a le plus de concurrence il y a
une forte concurrence sur sur CDG mais
une grosse concurrence aussi sur les
États-Unis parce que c'est là où il y a
eu le plus de capacités on a des niveaux
tarifaires sur un aller-retour à Los
Angeles Papeete autour de 450 dollars
c'est à dire pratiquement à Paris Nice
ou un pari de Toulouse voilà sur 8
heures de vol sur un gros porteur en
vend au prix d'un Paris-Nice à peu près
je le fais je le fais à la louche
donc l'offre effectivement du point de
vue des compagnies l'offre de
des sièges en fait elle subit l'offre
aérienne subit
subit une carence en termes d'offres
réceptif il n'y a pas assez de chambres
d'hôtel il y a pas assez de Airbnb à
cette pension de famille donc on arrive
très vite malgré la stimulation par les
prix on arrive très vite à des refus de
vente dans notre jargon ce qu'on appelle
des subst cells parce qu'effectivement
notre clientèle qui est essentiellement
constituée là je parle pour toutes les
compagnies d'ailleurs qui est
essentiellement constituée de de
touristes puisque c'est du 20 à 80 à peu
près 80 25% de la cabine c'est des
Polynésiens le reste c'est les touristes
donc on arrive très vite avec la
saturation de l'offre en hébergement on
arrive très vite à perdre malgré la
stimulation par les prix on perd on perd
du trafic puisque les touristes ne
peuvent pas forcément l'hébergement
[Musique]
qui fait que l'originalité parce que je
sais que je pense que votre
l'audition de ce matin et d'actualité
puisque effectivement on suit les médias
est lié à l'offre à la à l'augmentation
des tarifs aériens notamment vers les
départements d'outre-mer puisqu'en suit
je suis l'actualité j'ai vu l'étude d'un
agrégateur c'est misterfly je crois
qu'elle publie une étude sur le sujet et
on a constaté effectivement qu'il y
avait au départ de la métropole il y
avait des os tarifaires de 20 à 40%
sur les tarifs aériens l'originalité de
la Polynésie c'est qu'il y a pas c'est
que nous on est à moins 2% c'est ce
qu'on constate d'ailleurs dans les prix
d'air tahitiwi de sur les tarifs depuis
2013 on avait on est on a perdu avec
l'arrivée des nouvelles compagnies on
avait perdu à peu près 10 %
jusqu'en 2018
l'arrivée de French bean notamment du
night-ed avait fait chuter les tarifs de
peu près 10% ensuite il y a eu la covid
c'est les tarifs moyens en classe
Économie en classe économique
puisque au départ de Los Angeles nous on
a constaté des baisses de recettes
unitaire de entre 20 et pouvant aller en
fonction de l'assaisonnalité à 40%. on
est monté jusqu'à moins 40% en recettes
unitaire sur le
au départ de Los Angeles mais
globalement si on prend le
j'imagine vous intéresse le Papeete
Paris sur le pape était Paris on est à
peu près depuis 2013 si on prend la
référence de 2013 donc il y a 10 ans on
est à peu près à moins 2% sur le tarif
des billets d'avion
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas passé et on a
si on aborde maintenant les questions
particulières notamment sur les tarifs
nous n'avons pas passé de surcharge
carburant mais on peut pas pu nous
n'avons pas pu répercuter le coup du
carburant qui est important en carburant
pour Tahiti Nice ça représente à peu
près 33% de nos charges c'est le premier
poste devant les salaires
et nous n'avons pas pu passer on va
essayer donc je sais pas si c'est pour
nous c'est
ce serait une bonne nouvelle je suis pas
sûr peut-être pour vous pour les
consommateurs mais on va essayer de
passer de la surcharge carburant je dis
bien on va essayer parce qu'on a déjà
fait des tentatives et ça n'est pas
passé dans le sens où effectivement la
concurrence n'a pas su forcément suivi
et donc sur toute l'année 2022 il y a
pas un franc qui est passé en surcharge
carburant
les prix les prix sont très bas n'ont
jamais été aussi bas
peu près puisque alors la structure d'un
billet d'avion c'est pas évident parce
que bon ça a été expliqué tantôt nous on
est soumis à une très forte saisonnalité
et effectivement on fait du on fait du
revenu management du île management donc
il y a pas un tarif fixe il y a pas un
tarif
harmonisé à l'année nos tarifs en
fonction de l'offre et de la demande
d'où cette baisse effectivement cette
forte baisse de en 2022 puisque il y a
une offre qui est largement supérieure à
la demande
et bon pour pour faire simple à peu près
sur un pari Charles sur un pari
à l'année sur un pari papeté ou pas
péter pas Paris parce que nous on a une
notion d'origine destination donc à pape
était Paris sera pas vendu au même prix
comme Paris Papeete en fonction toujours
de la demande et de l'offre ou d'un Los
Angeles papeter donc lampe papeter les
tarifs vont varier en fonction de
l'origine de la destination mais je
dirais que sur un aller-retour Charles
de Gaulle
Papeete
les taxes ça va être entre 7 et 10%, le
carburant c'est à peu près 15% et le
reste et le tarif de base quel tarif de
base va varier bien sûr en fonction de
l'offre et de la demande
donc aujourd'hui sur le kérosène je lis
en même temps vos questions sur lequel
sur le cours du kérosène il est resté
malgré tout assez élevé c'est vrai qu'il
fait un peu le yoyo depuis quelques
temps mais nous par rapport au Brent il
est toujours plus élevé que le bras hein
faut rajouter souvent entre 20 et 30
dollars nous c'est le jet kerosen
Singapour logics qui est autour de la
qui est cette année en 2022 a toujours
varié entre eux entre 110 120 jusqu'à
130 dollars encore moyen donc là je pour
vous donner une idée que là il est on
est monté jusqu'à 130 là en ce moment il
y a ces derniers temps il est redescendu
un peu et bon de toute façon comme on
l'absorbait on pense pas baisser bien
sûr pour nous
baisser les prix des billets d'avion
c'est quelque chose qui est pas à
l'ordre du jour puisqu'on est déjà à des
prix extrêmement bas
et puis je crois qu'il y avait une
question aussi sur le tarif fixe donc
l'effet saisonnalité saisonnalité pardon
avec tarif fixe c'est pas évident c'est
difficile d'appliquer un tarif fixe à
l'année donc le modèle Corse est
vraiment très particulier avec cette DSP
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je viens d'avoir une belle annonce de
Marc Walla sur la continuité
territoriale c'est vrai que nos clients
l'utilisent beaucoup parce qu'en général
c'est nous nous avons comme toutes les
compagnies qui desservent l'Hexagone on
a signé des accords une convention avec
l'État puisque c'est l'État qui qui
distribue les aides sur la continuité
territoriale et c'est le passager qui
suivront ça s'interne de critères
d'éligibilité le passager reçoit ses
aides directement et nous achètent les
billets d'avion et donc c'est quelque
chose qui marche assez bien la
continuité territoriale c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle que l'enveloppe
budgétaire soit j'imagine soit un peu
augmenté mais bon
ça pas non c'est pas je dirais comment
transporte quand même beaucoup de
touristes c'est pas forcément ce qui va
rendre les routes à l'équilibre c'est
une aide à appréciable continuité
territoriale surtout effectivement pour
ceux qui ont bénéficient mais nous
notre notre challenge il est au niveau
de la concurrence il est au niveau de
l'eau française et surtout surtout
l'offre réceptive qui est qui est pas on
adéquation aujourd'hui avec le français
elle a un peu les
que je pouvais dire rapidement par
rapport à votre question et pour
compléter effectivement les
interventions très complètes du
vice-président et de Marc wallah du SEAC
Polynésie
et je suis prêt à répondre à toutes vos
questions
merci monsieur je vais maintenant passer
la parole à nous du rapporteurs donc
nous allons débuter avec Catherine
Concorde puis Guillaume Chevrolet
merci je suis un collègue Micheline
Jacques bon rebonjour à toutes et à tous
j'aurais deux questions la première
si je comprends bien
l'octroi d'une aide à la continuité
territoriale va ou de l'Hexagone
est soumise à condition c'est-à-dire ses
fonctions vous avez donc des barèmes de
conditions des élèves boursiers donc il
y a une acuité en condition de vie moyen
qui conditionne cette aide à la
continuité territoriale est-ce que vous
envisagez dans le dispositif avec l'État
moyen qui permettrait d'aller au-delà de
cette barrière de conditions de vie et
les boursiers etc est-ce que vous
envisagez également un accompagnement de
la collectivité
pour du gouvernement donc de Polynésie
pour augmenter éventuellement la peau
mission un billet d'avion à destination
de de des populations ça c'est ma
première question et puis une deuxième
qui m'était Opel vous avez dit ne pas
voir en repère occulter là je m'adresse
en particulier au compagnie aérienne de
pas avoir et à la dgacé à ne pas voir
l'hypercuité la hausse des carburants
directement sur le billet mais comment
tout cela tient quand on sait que la
part du carburant et essentiel dans la
composition du pli comme on vous avait
fait pour ne pas rire bientôt hier et
rester dans des prix qui n'ont pas
augmenté
merci Catherine
oui merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues messieurs merci pour vos
interventions très complètes dans le
prolongement de ma collègue Catherine
Concorde j'aurais une question sur sur
les cette aide à la continuité
territoriale est-ce que vous considérez
que les dispositifs sont bien connus par
l'ensemble des habitants du territoire
polynésien vous avez évoqué que il y
avait
20% de Polynésiens à voyager vers la
vers la métropole est-ce que ce sont des
déshabitués ou est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
un renouvellement et est-ce que vous
vous êtes certains dans cet accès à ces
aides à cet accès aux droits par
internet ça a été indiqué que les
dispositifs sont bien connus et que on
s'adresse à un maximum de nos
concitoyens de de ces territoires
une deuxième question sur le vous avez
évoqué les critères de santé est-ce que
ces cumulatif ou par rapport aux
critères financiers ou ce que pour des
raisons de santé il y a un accès plus
large en raison médicale ou est-ce que
il y a des critères financiers également
et une question qui s'adresse à aux
compagnies aériennes vous avez fait état
de prix particulièrement en bas du fait
de d'un contexte concurrentiel très très
important est-ce que au niveau de vos
marges et de la rentabilité de vos
entreprises ou est-ce que vous vous
situez merci
si vous voulez bien je vais laisser la
parole aussi Lana notre
si elle a quelque chose à ajouter
merci madame la Présidente non tout a
été dit je voudrais juste saluer il y
aura dans d'autres veines chez vous ben
il fait nuit ici à Paris
monsieur le vice-président Jean salut
enfin j'ai trouvé
encore dit j'ai bien encore dit parce
que je suis quand même porteur de la
mission sur RTI ce qui a été rappelé par
notre vice-président
c'est pas fait la DGAC de Peretti
j'écris que tu étais parti déjà à la
retraite salut depuis Paris par contre
par contre Monsieur le Président
il y a il y a un point sur lequel je
vais beaucoup m'attarder et c'est précis
en tout cas je m'adresse aux rapporteur
à mes collègues c'est la continuité
territoriale jusqu'à la résidence et
c'était important de rappeler parce que
aujourd'hui ici à Paris on parle de
Paris propriétés mais on oublie par
exemple moi je suis dési sous le vent il
y a les Marquises il faudrait peut-être
aménager ici à Paris à ce qu'on parle de
la continuité
de Paris jusqu'à la résidence jusqu'à
l'île de résidence et puis un combat
aussi monsieur le président de la
délégation et ça je vais pas en démo de
la continuité interdit
parler de Paris et
oui entre les étudiants ceux qui
viennent en formation les
accompagnateurs
de malades et puis il y a aussi la
continuité
ça c'est le vrai sujet aussi enfin que
je suis en train de soumettre à mes à
mes collègues rapporteur c'est important
on a évoqué le prix d'un propriétaire
marquise à 650 euros
au prix qui vient d'être annoncé par le
PDG salut Michel de MTI nuit offrons les
450 dollars pour aller propriété Los
Angeles que
omarquise mais je défends le pays le
fait noir rassurez-vous voilà un peu ce
qui me ce qui me passe par la tête en
tout cas ce soir en tout cas merci à
tous d'avoir répondu
je puisse vous assurer que l'émission du
Sénat n'est-ce pas Madame Concorde
monsieur le Président l'émission du
Sénat c'est pas juste un mot pour
auditionner des personnes et puis me
remettre des rapports qui vont rester au
placard pour assurer je vais surveiller
de très près les travaux sur cette
sucette mission voilà ma Loulou
merci Dana et je peux t'assurer que je
te rejoins sur ce que vous êtes ce que
tu avais la continuité intérim puisque
lorsqu'on habite dans un archipel on
mesure ce que c'est ce que c'est quelles
sont les difficultés
j'aurais juste avant de laisser la
parole pour la réponse monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
l'importance du déploiement d'Internet
permettant un meilleur accès au service
administratif pensez vous que la
continuité numérique pourrait être une
solution pour un meilleur accès à la
formation professionnelle et à la
télémédecine pour tous
et dernière question et je vous réponds
merci pour
pour vos questions qui ont vraiment une
pertinence dans le contexte polynésien
je vais commencer par
la symétrie Catherine je crois qui est
intervenu et qui est donné question sur
une question de conditions de ressources
oui il existe des un plafonds de revenus
c'est du domaine évidemment la décision
de l'état de fixer ces conditions de
ressources en l'occurrence je vais vous
les donner puisque on les a communiqué
sur la quantité territoriale il faut
gagner moins de 1200 euros par mois
une c'est une condition et pour les
questions de passeport mobilité
gagner moins de 26000 euros par an
c'est-à-dire
environ 2000 euros par mois ce sont donc
les conditions vous poser la question
savoir est-ce que est-ce que le pays a
dans ses intentions le fait de
participer sur le financement de la
continuité territoriale
j'évoquais cette question
tantôt notamment sur
la volonté de la Polynésie mais c'était
dans les années 2001
de contribuer de mettre en place cette
contribution au côté de l'État cette
cette
réglementation ou cette délibération je
crois à l'époque je me rappelle plus une
délibération de l'assemblée à l'arrêter
du Conseil des ministres
a été fait l'objet d'un recours devant
le Conseil d'État qui a jugé qui n'était
pas dans la compétence du pays de
financer donc
cette leçon de continuité territoriale
il faudrait une analyse juridique
dans le contexte du statut de la plus
française d'abord de 2004 évidemment
évoluer depuis un pouvoir les
dispositions qui peut être prises pour
le permettre vous voyez je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure
d'un souhait de la Polynésie française
de voir l'état auprès de nous sur le
financement de la continuité
territoriale intérieure pour agir sur la
baisse des prix il convient et ça c'est
certainement discussion à débat que nous
devrions avoir avec l'État et si
évidemment la réglementation permet à
voir dans quelle mesure à l'avenir le
pays pourrait renforcer ce dispositif de
continuité territoriale et peut-être
mieux aider
non seulement en
prise en charge tarifaire des billets
d'avion et mais aussi
objectifs supplémentaires puisque ça a
été dit tout à l'heure
le budget de la continuité territoriale
qui est dans l'Union
annuellement et consommer à 100% ça veut
dire qu'il y a bien des dossiers et ne
sont pas prises en charge et je
regardais d'ailleurs la note de l'État
qui fait bien allusion à un nombre
constitué de dossiers de demande et à
des réponses apportées à part le pôle de
continuité territoriale locale un niveau
qui est inférieur à la demande donc il
faudra je pense qu'il y a un effort
supplémentaire qui soit réalisé à
l'avenir
la deuxième sénateur qui est intervenu
pose la question savoir s'ils sont des
dispositifs qui sont bien connues des
Polynésiens oui
nous avons souvent y compris d'ailleurs
dans dans les ministères ou dans les
services du pays et je pense notamment
c'est Philippe des demandes non
seulement d'explication mais de tête à
l'accompagnement je pense notamment sur
le plan un professionnel par exemple en
matière de formation
et donc tout se dispositif est un
dispositif sur la grande dignité
territoriale sur le passeport mobilité
et sont des dispositifs connus
utilisés par les Polynésiens qui partent
pour se former qui partent en stage qui
part pour passer des concours il y en a
pas énormément mais disons que voilà
c'est dispositifs l'ensemble de ces
besoins et
et donc c'est bien connu sur l'ensemble
du territoire je vais directement sur
une question qui a été posée par Madame
la rapporteur
sur le fait de savoir si l'Internet peut
aider
je dirais
à
ces questions de formation oui bien sûr
nous avons déjà au niveau du pays mis en
place des dispositifs de formation à
distance c'est le cas des pompiers de
nos plateformes aéroportuaires qui se
forment on dirait que avec l'entreprise
ziforza qui est situé quelque part à
Toulouse donc c'est déjà un outil qui
est rentré dans le cadre des formations
qui sont dispensés et qui ne nécessitent
pas forcément le déplacement
physique des personnes sur la métropole
ou d'ailleurs entre les îles et puis et
puis Papeete
des avancées
notamment par rapport au CNAM par
rapport à l'université de la pénibilité
française qui dispense également des
cours
sur sur l'Internet en direct en visio
avec des professeurs situés sur une
principale donc c'est quelque chose qui
est rentré
aujourd'hui dans les mœurs et tout cela
est dû au réseau au tissage du câble
[Musique]
du câble numérique a été mise en place
c'est qui permet un grand nombre d'îles
de pouvoir disposer du très haut débit
voire même du haut débit pour les îles
qui n'ont pas de câble et qui sont
arrosés sur le plan des réseaux
donc c'est nous avons vraiment un
dispositif en Polynésie et qui permet
tout ça d'ailleurs la télémédecine
en termes de consultation et quelque
chose qui est déjà en place notre
souhait c'est évidemment avec les
valises
médicales c'est d'aller un peu plus loin
avec notre dispositif de ressources
humaines situées dans les îles
que ce soit des aides soignantes que ce
soit des infirmières avec la possibilité
on leur fait il y a pas très longtemps
dans une île qui est qui est éloigné de
500 km de l'huile de tétine ne dispose
pas d'aéroports et ni le moyen
sophistiqué de déplacement nous avons
des connexions internet avec des
interventions en consultation de la part
des médecins
et avec les valises nous pourrons aller
beaucoup plus loin sur les consultations
avec les données transmises depuis
depuis ces
îles ou ces régions
voilà pour répondre aux dernières
questions de Madame la rapporteur je
reviens maintenant sur
que quelques questions qui touchent
que
l'intervention de notre sénatrice
bonjour Lana
alors j'ai la continuité jusqu'à la
résidence et bien clair que si nous
avions une population concentrée sur
l'île de Tahiti Montréal
et qui aurait la possibilité un peu
comme dans la région parisienne de se
rendre sur l'aéroport de CDG ou sur Orly
et pas de problème surtout qu'il y a des
réseaux
de transport public existe chez nous il
n'y a pas nous avons
un tiers de notre population
qui vit sur les isolants au toit moto en
marquise et aux Australes
ces gens qui utilisent le seul moyen de
transport qui est l'avion paye
évidemment au tarifs prévus avec une
prise en charge de la délégation de
service public que j'évoquais tantôt
lorsque évidemment ce sont des aéroports
qui sont concernés
mais c'est une prise à la prise en
charge
je vais vous donner un exemple sur
sur
[Musique]
couvert évidemment du directeur général
de hertzi ce sont des tarifs quand même
de 40 000 francs c'est à dire de 350
euros si vous voulez donc
ça devient tout de suite très
problématique pour des gens qui font du
contrat sur les atomes pour des gens qui
font de la pêche et qui ne sont pas des
gens fortunés ce sont des gens
d'ailleurs qui répondent complètement
critères que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
concernant les conditions de ressources
pour pouvoir bénéficier de la continuité
territoriale au Centre en France
métropolitaine mais Grégoire débourser
certaines choses pour venir sur
l'hypothétie et bénéficier de cette
continuité territoriale
donc ce serait une belle avancée si on
pouvait dans le cadre de votre rapport
intégrer ces particularités de nos
collectivités éclatées sur sur un océan
dans un contexte d'ailleurs où on
s'intéresse beaucoup à la Polynésie
la Nouvelle-Calédonie avec l'action ado
Pacifique je crois que aujourd'hui
véritablement
se déploiement de la continuité
territoriale aux réputant un sens et à
l'intérêt sur le fait que les fins se
penchent sur cet aspect
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre je
crois que Madame cancone souhaite
prendre la parole Catherine
oui oui bonjour Pour re-bonjour pour
rassurer tout le monde particulier la
nage quoi que les rapports du Sénat sont
des
encore récemment en présence de
stéphaneau le président de la
collectivité de la Martinique a répété
plusieurs fois cette inspirée des
rapports du Sénat pour ses propres lois
quand il était député et même sur la
construction de certaines politiques
publiques à l'intérieur de sa
collectivité c'est le cas par exemple
pour un rapport sport de haut niveau que
nous avons mené où il y a aujourd'hui
des déclinaisons extrêmement concrètes
qui sont issues de cela donc pour
l'instant nous sommes vraiment
investigations il faut que nous
puissions faire le tour de manière
globale des dispositifs qui existent
dans tous les dans tous les dans tous
les pays de la vie d'outre-mer je
remercie aussi les services du Sénat qui
ont qui nous ont transmisés en excellent
boulot sur une sorte de benchmark
comparatif entre des dispositifs les
autres rues voire même de d'autres pays
d'Europe puisqu'il y a pas que nous qui
sommes concernés par la continuité
territoriale il y a aussi les rues
espagnoles comme les
portugaises et espagnol ils açorent les
Canaries qui qui eux aussi mis en place
des dispositifs donc vraiment merci pour
ce rapport qu'on a reçu hier qui est
excellent et puis là nous sommes
vraiment très de construire ce que nous
souhaitons être une petite révolution
dans le cadre de la continuité
territoriale on a commencé avec la cause
qui est un système aléas assez idyllique
on pourrait dire très intéressant qui
pourrait inspirer totalement payé par
l'État plus de 200 millions d'euros pour
l'équivalent des habitants de la
Martinique par exemple et vraiment il
faut il faut qu'on aille au fond en tout
en étant objectif idéaliste on ne pourra
pas tout faire parce que derrière il y a
quand même des considérations
budgétaires et financières qu'il faut
pas oublier mais là aussi dans le bassin
Atlantique on est très par les poèmes de
continuité
territoriales pas dans les mêmes
proportions que la Polynésie mais
également sur le fond parce que
Micheline Jacques notre vice-président
qui officie en ce moment au Sénat dans
cette audition et ben elle doit passer
de Saint-Barthélemy qui a un
microscopique aéroport pour aller
en Guadeloupe à saint-martiner
éventuellement prendre son Boeing pour
aller où sont néobus pour aller à Paris
il y a aussi des problèmes de continuité
dans l'archipel la Guadeloupe a par
exemple mis en place des DSP avec des
transports sur maritimes pour assurer
les transports entre la Désirade entre
Marie-Galante qui sont des îles de
l'archipel Guadeloupe mais des toutes
petites îles sur lesquelles par exemple
il y a pas de lycée donc il faut pouvoir
ramener les gamins à l'école sur entre
guillemets le continent guadeloupéen et
puis à l'intérieur même de la Guyane ou
de nous devons nous rendre fin février
dans le cadre de la délégation il y a
aussi d'immenses problèmes aiguilles
annoncé que c'est un pays immense avec
des populations autochtones qui sont
très isolées et qui doivent elles aussi
donc vraiment merci pour toutes ces
explications qui nous ont été données
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment très très
important mais je crois que je n'ai pas
eu la réponse concernant les carburants
la notion de carburant comment vous
n'avez pas l'iputé il y a un moment où
j'ai une interruption de ma bande
passante est-ce que c'est à ce moment-là
que vous avez répondu mais j'aimerais
bien savoir un parquet tour de magie
vous
occupé sur le prix du billet
l'augmentation très importante de la pas
encore au bureau depuis guerre en
Ukraine et toutes les contrées que l'on
connaît en ce moment sur le marché
international merci Catherine en fait
c'est que je pense je comptais donner la
parole justement
au fur et à mesure donc monsieur
marcuala avez-vous quelques quelque
chose à rajouter
je pense que très sincèrement tout a été
dit sur la partie
aide subvention sur la partie sur la
continuité territoriale et je vais
laisser les compagnies aériennes
répondre aux questions sur le non
répercussion du coût du carburant
puisqu'en fait c'est elle qui gère la
politique commerciale je vous remercie
alors je vais laisser la parole à me
suivre
concernant le
cas où et l'augmentation sans
augmentation
connue l'année dernière ce qu'il faut
prendre en considération pour
l'accompagner athlétisme et que nous
opérons des Ath des athères sont des
avions les plus économiques en termes de
de consommation de carburant rapporté au
siège offert donc grosso modo
les charges de carburant pour être Haïti
le présente à peu près une 10 à 13% de
décharges totales de la compagnie donc
l'augmentation du prix du carburant a pu
effectivement être absorbé à notre
niveau et cela aussi consécutivement on
fait que
des dès lors que nous allons nous sommes
rentrés dans la crise du covid nous
avons réalisé énormément d'économies
nous avons fait un gros gros travail sur
nos charges qui a remporté leur fille
ensuite de leur collectivité a repris en
2022 et de manière relativement
importante ce qui fait que nous avons
effectivement comme je disais miser sur
le fait que nous allions transporter en
2022 et en 2023 d'ailleurs aussi plus de
passagers que les années précédentes et
nous avons effectivement pu de cette
façon
ne pas en fait répercuter de hausse sur
les prix des billets voire même
consulter une voilà un peu la situation
concerne pour répondre à la question que
vous vous êtes posés donc RDT
aujourd'hui
a terminé 2022
en équilibre
à dégager une image que je qualifie de
très très raisonnable pour ma part je
souhaite pas contre profiter de du temps
de parole qui m'est donné là pour
accompagner d'une certaine façon un
petit peu et insister sur ce point-là
les propos du vice-président à propos de
la continuité
territoriale
intrainsulaire pour les îles françaises
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que je
pense que on n'en prend pas assez
on n'a pas assez
conscience à l'échelle de la métropole
mais j'ai derrière moi si vous êtes
difficile de le voir mais j'ai dit
réellement une carte de la poignée
française qui est suppose superposé à
celle de l'Europe et quand on part au
Marquises si on met la l'île de Tahiti
sur Paris c'est comme si qu'on allait à
Stockholm
voilà c'est pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée et quand on va quand on va du
côté de des grands billets c'est comme
si qu'on allait à Budapest
voilà un peu l'ordre de distance que
nous avons nous en interne donc
effectivement la problématique de
continuité territoriale se pose en
interne à la police française et de
manière cruciale parce que les passagers
n'ont pas d'autres solutions que de
prendre l'avion effectivement nous avons
affaire à des populations qui sont
dispersées sur un territoire qui est
énorme ces populations sont très faibles
sur les différentes destinations que
nous avons ce qui explique que nous ne
pouvons pas avoir des trafics très
importants sur ces îles et donc dans ces
conditions nous sommes contraints à
utiliser des modules qui sont des
modules de petite taille comme les
athées par exemple et donc utiliser un
ADR dans ce type de réseau et bien
génial effectivement ramener au siège
des coups qui sont relativement
importants et beaucoup plus importants
que lorsque l'on est sur des trafics sur
des relations je dirais
international avec des trafics très
importants et donc la possibilité
d'utiliser des modules qui sont
donc
je dirais l'environnement économique est
très particulier et contribue
effectivement à exposer la clientèle
locale insulaire à des coûts de
transport par avion qui sont
relativement élevés d'où effectivement
le fait que depuis quelques temps que
nous avions nous avons desservi
longtemps des lignes qui étaient
structuellement déficitée avec pour des
qualités pas possible de revenir à
l'équilibre et sur lesquels donc le
territoire le pays plutôt a décidé
d'intervenir en mettant en place une
délégation de délégation de service
public voilà ça c'est je donc pour moi
effectivement il y a je pense à
l'intérêt particulier à voir l'état
venir contribuer à ce fond de
téléquation que le pays a mis en place
et cela effectivement de manière à comme
le disait le vice-président non
seulement peut-être aider ou soulager le
pays de de sa cont propre mais surtout
en fait
baisser en fait la contribution des
passagers parce que ce fond il faut pas
l'oublier est financé par les passagers
dans la globalité baisser dans cette
contribution de dépasser ou des
enclavagements des îles voilà je vous
remercie et je vais nous allons terminer
avec Monsieur Michel mon voisin pour les
auditions
à propos de la question de Madame
Concorde
oui bien sûr je trouve ça que j'avais
levé la main pour répondre sur la
question de la répercussion du carburant
et de la rentabilité
déjà je voulais juste corriger
une question qui s'est posée je crois
sur Delta et Air France on a
présenté Delta comme une nouvelle
compagnie ce qui n'est pas le cas sur
notre dessert c'est vrai qu'on a oublié
de le préciser Air France et Delta sont
en co-entreprise sur le transatlantique
mais également sur la destination Los
Angeles papete ça veut dire qu'il
partage les recettes les charges ils ont
une immunité anti trust c'est à dire
qu'ils discutent des prix il fixe
ensemble les tarifs qui interdit dans le
transport aérien sauf effectivement
quand on a cette fameuse immunité
antitrust
qui est très surveillé d'ailleurs par le
Département d'État au transport aux
États-Unis donc si vous voulez pour nous
quand Air France était à trois
fréquences ils sont passés à cinq
fréquences et pour nous aujourd'hui ils
sont à 8 quand on rajoute les trois
fréquences de Delta c'est pas ça fait 8
fréquences pour le couple Delta Air
France pourquoi je dis ça parce que
c'est sûr capacité en fait sont des
compagnies
pour arriver à la rentabilité sont des
compagnies ce que ce qu'a amené la crise
covid c'est que les États en soutenu
leur compagnie nationale même si delta
est une compagnie privée les médias bon
air France a des bénéficié d'aide
massives
et les grandes compagnies les grandes
compagnies d’état les grands étangs
soutenus leur grandes compagnie ce qui
là dessus il y a pas de débat c'est tout
à fait normal là où on pourrait être un
peu plus critique c'est que les États
n'ont pas contrôlé ce que les compagnons
fait de ce de ce cache ils ont touché
beaucoup de cash parce que c'est des
versements
son nom est prévu son trébuchant donc
les États n'ont pas contrôlé aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on constate c'est que ces
grandes compagnies elles mettent de la
surcapacité sur les routes d'abord
l'Asie c'est pas réouvert donc elles ont
de la capacité elles ont des avions
elles ont des avions en place donc elle
les place et elles mettent des
surcapacités qui quelque part vise à se
fixer les petites compagnies c'est un
peu le problème qu'on a nous en tout cas
les compagnies d'outre-mer on a bien vu
la situation des Australes vous entendez
régulièrement Marc rocher intervenir
pour French beer Caraïbes on fait face à
une concurrence qui est vraiment très
dure là dessus alors pour le carburant
pour qu'on l'appareil percuté c'est
l'effet concurrence alors comment on
fait comment on fait en serre nos
charges concernant Arte inouï on a fait
un plan de départ qui a fait partir 20%
du personnel pendant la crise covid
depuis on recrute mais alors au
compte-goutte
le personnel fait des efforts colossaux
on est toujours sous le coup d'une
baisse des salaires de -5% jusqu'à fin
2023 c'est un protocole d'accord qui
avait été signé avec le personnel en
pleine Crisco vide en matière
d'inflation on leur a donné un ennemi
pour cent d'augmentation qu'on les
autres certaines compagnies ont donné
jusqu'à 5
%. c'est nous on a été
on a été alors c'est des discussions
qu'on a effectivement qui est
représentations syndicales mais
bon ils comprennent que la situation est
critique et qu'il faut effectivement que
le personne puisque les salaires après
le kérosène c'est le deuxième poste de
charge et donc c'est là dessus qu'on
joue on essaie de négocier avec nos
fournisseurs également des des gels
tarifaires ou des best tarifaires mais
ça c'est pas le plus facile c'est même
l'inverse est beaucoup d'inflation sur
nos charges notamment les charges
d'aéroports unis tous les aéroports
américains ont augmenté leurs charges
les prestataires aussi puisque
avec le départ avec la contraction de
personnel ils ont du mal à recruter du
coup ils sont très sélectifs sur les
compagnies qui qui gardent et ils
augmentent les tarifs je pense aux
prestataires au passage à l'aéroport sur
les aéroports internationaux les quatre
heures enfin tout nos fournisseurs et
l'inflation forte donc la conséquence
c'est quoi c'est une c'est une
dégradation de notre rentabilité
dégradation forte de notre
rentabilité on a des non marges à son
négatives
[Musique]
2022 probablement 2023 on est sur des
marges négatives donc on a effectivement
par contre de quoi bon on a eu on a eu
nous aussi des aides de la de la
collectivité d'abord puisque le notre
actionnaire principal a bénéficié d'un
PGE qu'il nous a reversé pour commander
une selle il faut savoir que nous on est
une société d'économie mixte donc on a
la possibilité de recevoir des
subventions d'équilibre on dirait c'est
une forme publique oui c'est des fonds
publics sont des subventions d'équilibre
entre le pays à cette faculté de nous
remettre à l'équilibre sur la base
d'exercice d'effic difficile
on a eu les aides classiques également
de l'État l'aide à la fermeture
administrative et les aides de fond de
solidarité donc ça c'était les règles
nationales on a bénéficié des règles
nationales donc ces aides ont fait que
air tahitiwi était rentré dans la crise
solide vous avez nous avions plus de six
mois de chiffre d'affaires en trésorerie
ce qui pourrait accompagnée aérienne et
beaucoup donc nous étions solides avant
la crise
on a consommé beaucoup de cash pendant
la crise on a consommé des fonds propres
mais les aides les aides de notre
actionnaires plus les aides de l'État en
fait qu'on a toujours cette trésorerie
on bénéficie toujours d'une trésorerie
importante qui nous permet de tenir et
bon mais oui la rentabilité en fait la
rentabilité des grades et dégradé ne pas
répercuter le carburant normalement nous
aurions dû répercuter le carburant de ne
pas l'avoir fait en fait on a le
tourisme est revenu en masse et l'année
2022 a été bonne pour les dans les
remplissages ce qui fait qu'en fait
notre performance et nous on a peu perdu
en fait en rapport
on a bien sûr concédé des parts de
marché mais c'était déjà le cas avec
l'arrivée des compagnies aériennes avant
covid mais globalement performe plutôt
bien en termes de remplissage des
remplissage qui sont bons notamment sur
Paris mais bon toute la performance
toute la performance de la compagnie
aérienne est partie dans le carburant
c'est-à-dire en appliquant pas de
surcharge carburant on a pris à notre
charge de carburant et ben voilà si
effectivement on avait pu répercuter le
carburant dans nos prix on aurait
aujourd'hui on serait comme RTI dans des
on serait à l'équilibre on serait même
légèrement excédentaire en résultat mais
ce qui n'est pas le cas on est en train
d'arrêter les comptes et il est probable
qu'en fait les pertes de la compagnie
correspondent à la hausse du carburant
que nous avons dû absorber merci
monsieur le Président le directeur
général donc je vais si vous n'avez rien
à rajouter je vous remercie pour votre
participation puis je vais laisser la
parole à notre président Stéphane Artano
pour la conclusion
j'ai une question madame la Présidente
qui va appeler une réponse très très
courte je voudrais connaître le régime
des aéroports vous avez parlé de 46
aéroports pour domestiques est-ce qu'ils
sont tous de l'état de du gouvernement
de Polynésie et puis la deuxième
question là aussi pour une réponse
courte dans vos voyageurs quelle est la
part de tourisme et la banque
d'autochtones
Monsieur le Directeur de l'aviation
civile peut-être pourra répondre
l'ensemble des aéroports
appartiennent au pays sauf le l'aéroport
de
cette dernière question
effectivement
l'État a procédé au transfert des trois
derniers aéroports or l'aéroport
international
qui sont des aéroports avec des
pratiques
importants donc ce sont les trois
derniers aéroports qui ont fait l'objet
d'un transfert au niveau du pays pour
l'instant le pays gère en direct au
travers de la direction des essences
civiles du service local de la liaison
civile sur les domaines de compétences
du pays donc ces aéroports
sauf les trois qui ont été transférés
qui demeurent encore aujourd'hui sous le
mandat de Aéroport de Tahiti pour le
compte du pays sous forme de dulaote
sur la sur la deuxième question
concernant le nombre de touristes au
regard du nombre de voyageurs
polynésiens ou nationaux je crois que
Monsieur Mauvaisin vous a donné une
tendance tout à l'heure qui était de
dire environ un quart ou un tiers des
voyageurs sont des Polynésiens ou des
nationaux pour
congélationaux elle peut y avoir des
touristes évidemment
nationaux aussi mais disons que ça
représente un quart à Dieu et donc de
PACS sur le trafic aérien
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc je pense
que là nous allons clôturer je vais
laisser la parole à notre président
Stéphane Artano
pour te remercier d'avoir présidé cette
cette audition très riche et merci
vraiment pour vos apports respectifs et
des questionnements et je tiens
également à rassurer notre collègue la
nation la portée des rapports du Sénat
comme la rappeler Catherine Concorde qui
sont des rapports de grande qualité
généralement et je ne dis pas par
flagrant pour ceux qui nous écoutent
mais qui font l'objet d'un suivi très
régulier notamment dans le cadre d'un
nouveau produit une nouvelle procédure
qui a été mise en oeuvre par le Sénat du
suivi des recommandations ce qui veut
dire que ce rapport d'information fera
l'objet de recommandations qui feront
l'ouvrir d'un suivi très étroit et très
précis par les rapporteurs afin de nous
assurer effectivement que les mesures
préconisées aillent dans le bon sens et
qu'elle trouve surtout une traduction
opérationnelle c'est vraiment le souci
principal du Sénat et donc voilà je
tiens également à rassurer notre
collègue et ceux qui ont de très sur ce
point en tout cas merci à toutes et à
tous pour cette audition et à très vite
bien évidemment
et si on voit à tous